hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
will dieses video habt ihr glaube ich
alle schon erwartet ich zeige euch heute
nämlich meine küche wir wohnen jetzt
schon seit über einem jahr hier im haus
und seit er vor eineinhalb jahren nutze
ich jetzt auch schon die küche die war
nämlich hier zuerst fertig und ich
glaube ich jetzt habe ich wirklich so
ein erfahrungswert kann euch sagen was
mir gefällt was mir nicht ganz so gut
gefällt und kann euch wirklich die küche
zeigen
ich habe echt lange auch gebraucht um
meine küche einzuräumen denn man sieht
ihr erst im arbeitsprozess was für
werkzeuge ich brauche oder wo ist der
weg kürzer und ich hab wirklich ganz oft
die küche um geräumt aber jetzt glaube
ich habe ich so das perfekte
ordnungssystem gefunden
dieses würde ich euch aber einfach im
nächsten video zeigen und in diesem
video zeige ich euch jetzt die küche die
küchengeräte und ich hoffe ich kann eure
fragen aufgreifen die ihr so in letzter
zeit unter die videos geschrieben habt
ja das ist unsere küche so sieht sie aus
wir hatten ursprünglich ein bisschen
anders gestaltet wenn ihr euch erinnert
die ersten videos waren hier mit der
grünen rückwand und mit den
geschlossenen schränken und eins muss
ich vielleicht dazu sagen für mich ist
eine küche kein statussymbol sondern
eher so mittel zum zweck das heißt ich
brauche die küche weil ich hier arbeite
weil ich hier koche und backe ich muss
mich darin wohl fühlen ich muss alles
organisiert haben alles griffbereit
haben
und für mich war die optik war auch
wichtig aber wichtiger war für mich eher
der inhalt der küche also wie sehen die
schranke ihnen aus wie kann ich mein
werkzeug verstauen wo kann ich meine
lebensmittel lagern denn hier ist meine
küche nicht nur küche sondern eben auch
küche und vorratsraum weil wir dafür
keinen extra raum haben also musste ich
wirklich lange überlegen und lange
planen und in meinem alten küchen video
das ist schon echt 45 jahre her habe ich
auch gesagt geht zu einem küchen händler
vor ort lasst euch dort beraten erzählt
was ihr zu hause habt was er braucht und
schaut euch die sachen direkt vor ort
und so wird es dieses mal auch gemacht
ich habe die küche zusammen mit der
causa geplant mit der claudia frey aus
kandel sie hat dort das frei küchen
zentrum und sie hat sich wirklich auch
ganz viel zeit genommen
ich habe ja alles erzählt was ich backe
was ich koche wie viele werkzeuge ich
habe wir uns aufschrieb gemacht und ich
glaube es sind wirklich einige stunden
und einige tage vergangen bis wir dann
letztendlich diese küche hier so wie sie
hier steht fertig geplant hatten
also diese küche hier das ist im prinzip
wieder normale haushaltsbücher nur ein
bisschen großzügiger geplant denn ich
bin ja hier auch nicht alleine sondern
mein team ist auch immer mal hier wenn
ihr team events ich habe die ganze
kameratechnik hier und das erleichtert
mir zum einen und das arbeiten aber eben
auch dieses gemeinsame sein
und ich habe hier einfach viel stauraum
für unser ganzes equipment ich habe hier
die ganze dekoration die ganzen teller
tassen trocken teller die wir ebenso für
fotos fürs buch und so weiter brauchen
deswegen haben wir hier im prinzip den
ganzen stauraum geschaffen aber an sich
also was die haushaltsgeräte angeht was
hier die ausstattung angeht ist wirklich
alles wieder normaler haushalts küche
und die claudia die hat sogar diese
küche also die fälle küche hat so
genannt weil sich in kandel im küchen
zentrum stehen einfach ein bisschen
weniger bisschen abgespeckt eben ohne
diesen ganzen stauraum den ich jetzt
zusätzlich für mein kamera equipment
brauche und wir arbeiten hier auch
wirklich gerne mit dem team germany team
events mit kochen zusammen und deswegen
brauchen wir eben auch diese ganze
fläche was sich vielleicht noch vorneweg
direkt sagen möchte und eigentlich ganz
traurig dass ich sagen muss aber ich
sag's leber
die küche ist komplett bezahlt von mir
also ich habe nichts geschenkt bekommen
nichts gesponsert bekommen
ich habe alles so wie es hier drin steht
alles bezahlt ich sag's lieber gleich
weil ich glaub so der ein oder andere
denkt sich wahrscheinlich hat kann man
sich so eine große küche bauen wenn man
alles geschenkt kriegt nein das haben
wir nicht bekommen alles ist bezahlt vom
fußboden bis zur decke alles bezahlt und
so eine küche die kann man sich auch
nicht einfach mal so kaufen sowas kauft
man sich wirklich für die nächsten 20
oder 30 jahre ich weiß es auch von
meinen eltern die haben einfach einmal
in ihrem leben eine küche gekauft und
dann erst 40 jahre später die zweite
küche weil die alte dann wirklich nicht
mehr zu gebrauchen war und unsere alte
küche zum beispiel die steht immer noch
in unserer alten wohnung die haben wir
einfach an den nachmieter übergeben also
deswegen sonst hat muss er auch wirklich
mitgenommen
ja soviel dazu ich habe gedacht was sich
auch ansprechen muss ist dass man bei
küchen wirklich nicht nach trends geht
denn oftmals sich trennt küchen in roth
in pink dann diese optik und ich finde
da darf man nicht nach trend gehen eben
weil man diese küche für die nächsten 20
oder 30 jahre hat und mir wurde direkt
abgeraten von einer offenen küche sowie
sie eher so wie er sich hier seht weil
es hieß offene schränke die sind einfach
aus aber gerade die finde ich wirklich
trendy denn du kannst wirklich die optik
der küche
durch die offenen schränken selbst
bestimmen das heißt wenn ich jetzt
gerade keine weihnachtszeit habe dann
kann ich das auch mal sachen reinstellen
ich kann
petrol reinstellen oder senfgelb weil
mir ist richtig gut gefällt und kann so
individuell die optik meiner küche immer
wieder variieren und das finde ich
eigentlich schon richtig praktisch und
eben auch richtig trendy
also los gehts ich zeige euch jetzt die
küche und fange einfach ganz
chronologisch an von anfang bis zum ende
das heißt gestatten beim boden dann
zeige ich euch die schränke die
arbeitsplatte die küchengeräte und
daneben noch alles so drumherum
hier beim boden haben wir uns für einen
sichtbeton estrich entschieden da ist
auch hier komplett im ganzen gebäude im
ganzen erdgeschoss und deshalb einfach
super in der reinigung den haben wir bei
unserem volk beim norbert gesehen und
haben uns gedacht okay das müssen wir
auch machen
den haben wir bei mortimer machen lassen
aus hockenheim und ich finde es hat
einfach so diesen fabrik stehen der ist
super in der reinigung sieht von edel
aus und ich finde da passen auch diese
via platten perfekt dazu die haben wir
aus bacharach von den lieben almut und
dem norbert und das sind handgemachte
zement mosaic platten so ein bisschen
spanisch finde ich und hier sieht aus
als hätte ich einfach sondern teppich um
meine küchenarbeitsplatten legen also
sieht echt super schön aus und ich finde
es passt auch gut mit dem sichtbeton und
die via platten die haben wir auch
mehrmals im ganzen haus als in unseren
bädern drüben bei uns im eingang und die
sind einfach wunderschön
da hatten wir wirklich auch das problem
dass wir uns einfach nicht entscheiden
konnten
wenn man dann hier praktisch diese grün
dunkelroten gewählt daher hatten wir
auch anfangs die grüne wandfarbe die
aber dann doch nicht so gepasst hat und
hier strahlt einfach dieser zement
mosaik bodenteppich das sieht wirklich
super schön aus und es wirklich einfach
in der reinigung
dann geht es weiter mit den schränken
also die korpus der küche und da habe
ich wirklich aus unserem letzten
küchenkauf gelernt keine schränke mehr
zu nehmen sondern wirklich schubladen
also auszüge denn so hat man alles
wirklich im überblick man zieht die
schublade auf steht komplett den ganzen
inhalt kann sich noch zwischen
schubladen einbauen und hier die auszüge
sind wirklich ganz praktisch denn ihr
könnt hier unten große dinge lagern oben
dann kleinere dinge und ich mache dann
auch immer so dass ich die dinge die ich
hier jeden tag brauche und regelmäßig
brauche oben lagere und die sachen die
ich
weniger braucht unten damit ich mich
nicht so oft wirken muss weil meine knie
knacken und knirschen richtig ich darf
mich nicht blicken
ja hier beim waschbecken da habe ich
eine ganz schöne anordnung und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier an waschbecken aus ziel
granit also so ein stein waschbecken und
ist es wirklich gar nicht flecken
anfällig also da kann man wirklich auch
mal ganz getrost und spüllappen
weglassen und nicht abtrocknen uns
entstehen trotzdem keine flecken
zumal wer aber auch muss ich dazu sagen
eine wc-anlage haben also eine
enthärtungsanlage damit unser wasser
weich ist und eben nicht so kalkhaltig
ist denn wir wohnen hier in der region
da ist wirklich das wasser richtig hart
und ich am anfang hatten wir die bwt
anlage noch nicht und ich musste
irgendwie jede woche die kaffeemaschine
entkalken weil hier eben auch jeder
kaffee trinkt und jetzt müssen wir das
einfach nicht mehr genau dieses ziel
granit und hier habe ich die armatur
zeige ich euch gleich noch aber ich
finde die anordnung einfach ziemlich
cool
denn ich habe hier links meine
spülmaschine
hier kann ich dann so stehen und das
geschirr so ein bisschen vorspülen oder
eben essensreste entfernen und die
essensreste david direkt hier rechts
über mülleimer schmeißen
denn oftmals hat man ja das problem dass
der mülleimer direkt unter der spüle ist
das heißt hier
dann stehst du da machst du das geschirr
schmeißt es weg und muss dann hier
irgendwo einräume und der müll einfach
in meinem weg und hier habe ich einfach
den platz unter dem spülbecken genutzt
ist auch so ein blanco system für die
ganzen materialien das ganze spiel
werkzeug spülmaschinen salz und so
weiter und hier rechts dann einfach die
mülleimer weil wir echt viel müll
produzieren hier mit dem großen team
haben wir einfach zwei große müllbeutel
die haben ja noch ein bisschen glas zum
glas wegschmeißen und einfach nur ein
paar fahrräder und das finde ich
eigentlich so das cool so ihre tiefste
hier in der küche da staunt echt jeder
weil einfach die anordnung super ist
also wenn jetzt kein da macht die
anordnung wirklich so in der mitte ist
das spülbecken und rechts und links
mülleimer und spülmaschine
da rufen erinnert mich immer wie es in
anderen kleinen jungen dessen junges
gesicht steigen weiß nicht wie alt bist
du eigentlich ja 38 ich habe es doch
gewusst noch sei nichts hatte sich so
jung auf 38 vitro rasch verteilt sich
nur ein bisschen anders auf die
körpergröße
ich habe nichts gehört
es tut mir leid
und hier seht ihr auch ich habe alles
wirklich voller schubladen und innen
schubladen und diese einteiler
die habe ich von blumen da gibt's
übrigens das habe ich leider echt zu
spät entdeckt und zwar gibt es davon
blume seite blumen zonenplan da könnt
ihr nämlich im vorfeld befeuere küche
plant also wirklich zu spät gemacht zur
beta index nzx vorher gemacht da könnt
ihr eintragen was für geschehe ihr habt
wie viel besteck wie viele dosen wie
viele vorräte und dann könnt ihr euch
dort individuell die küche im prinzip so
ein bisschen vorplanen lassen und damit
dann einfach ins küchenstudio gehen denn
ich muss echt sozusagen die wenigsten
küchenstudios nehmen sich die zeit dafür
euch zu zeigen was in die schränke kommt
und ich finde gerade das innenleben ist
das wichtigste denn du musst wissen wo
du was verstoß damit du weißt wie du
arbeiten kannst und ich meine die optik
der küche das ist für mich so das letzte
was passiert und ich habe mich da echt
hingesetzt mit der claudia sie war
sozusagen mein zonenplan und mit ihr
habe ich wirklich gesagt okay ich habe
diese sachen zum verstauen und ich
brauche einfach die einteiler
und sie hat mich dann auch auf die firma
blumen gebracht denn die haben wirklich
ganz praktische schubladen innen systeme
aber eben auch korpus apotheken schränke
usw lösungen die wirklich ganz praktisch
sind und da könnt ihr euch wirklich
online richtig gut informieren was
glaube ich so das beste elf an blumen
das kann ich hier zeigen und zwar gibt
es endlich eine lösung für alle folie
und frischhaltefolie die auch wirklich
noch gut ist
guckt mal hier könnt ihr nämlich die
folie ich versuche natürlich immer wenig
zu benutzen aber wenn ich sie dann doch
mal brauche ich es hier schön
abschneiden dann weg transportieren wo
ich es eben brauche zum beispiel hier
direkt abdecken und dann nehmt ihr den
start rollt den hier wieder auf und
fertig genauso bei der folie hier ein
abschneiden und alles ist aber ganz
sauber sie verstehe ich jetzt denn die
benutze ich noch weiter und hier unten
benutze ich dann die abteile zum
beispiel auch gerade hier für die
schubladen und für das werkzeug also ich
hab meinen kitchen kenwood zubehör und
hab das dann einfach schön in den
abteilungen drin
entweder lässt man das gros sowie
hierfür wirklich großes werkzeug oder
man kann auch noch diese zwischen 1
teilnehmen und dann noch innen drin ein
teil
und wenn man direkt mit dem blues system
arbeitet gibt sogar hier an der seite
noch die funktion dass man hier was
komplett einsparen kann also das würde
ich wirklich beim nächsten mal genau so
machen und bei der küchenplanung habe
ich mir praktisch gedanken darüber
gemacht was mache ich wo und was möchte
ich wo verstauen
deswegen habe ich hier so den hinteren
bereich da ist er wirklich mülleimer
spüle und spülmaschine und links und
rechts davon habe ich meine
arbeitsgeräte die ich so immer wieder
brauche für gemüse vorbereiten
ich hab da die küchenmaschinen die
zubehörteile hier habe ich eher so
sachen wie haushaltsbücher also die
ganzen geschirrtücher und unten sachen
zum verstauen von lebensmittel und hier
in der mitte also beim kochfeld habe ich
dann meine töpfe und mein koch werkzeug
und hier im hintergrund da habe ich
meine backöfen die kaffeemaschine und da
verstehe ich im prinzip auch alles was
ich dafür brauche für mich war auch
wichtig dass ich wieder zwei backöfen
habe weil ich eben auch viel koche und
backe und viele haben ja die fünf sechs
oder zehn jahren die küche gekauft haben
haben sich im backofen gekauft und einen
dampfgarer das heißt man hatte da schon
zwei geräte und ich habe mir jetzt
einfach einen backofen mit dampfgarer
gekauft und einen backofen mit
mikrowelle das heißt ich hab so einfach
zwei in einem und ich habe sogar noch
eine mikrowelle gespart wobei wir keine
mikrowellen menschen sind aber jetzt wo
ich die mikrowelle mit drin haben finde
ich sie ganz gut denn ich kann so die
mikrowelle auch mit der heizung
kombinieren und zum beispiel viel viel
schneller kochen und alle küchengeräte
die ich habe sind von bosch serie 8 und
die habe ich ausgewählt weil sie einfach
eine gute qualität haben das
preis-leistungs-verhältnis stimmt und
weil sie eben auch regional sind dh die
dampfschiffen die werden alle für uns
hier in bretten gemacht und ich war
wirklich auf vielen messen auf vielen
küchen messen und haushalts messen und
habe einige geräte hersteller gefunden
und einige gesucht und viele
möbelhersteller und da hab ich mir
einfach so die rausgesucht die mir am
besten zugesagt haben und ich habe ich
zum beispiel den backofen der serie 8
das ist ein ganz normaler backofen plus
dampfgarer das heißt er kann auch zu
100% dampfgaren und ich kann den dampf
stoß daneben auch benutzen um zb bei
ober unterhitze was zu garen wo ich
einfach noch dampf schluss haben will
wir beim magischen paket zum beispiel
und hier links habe ich den backofen der
hat keine volldampf funktion dafür hat
er aber eine mikrowelle funktion und
eben noch so eine dampf stoß funktion
also der hat praktisch mikrowelle
normalen backofen unseren dampf stoß für
eben aufs magische baguette dort kann
ich aber nicht voll dampfgaren also das
geht dann eben nur in denen und in der
mitte haben wir dann noch rein weil es
eben gut passt die kaffeemaschine und
wir haben nichts mehr auf der
arbeitsfläche rumstehen was irgendwie zu
staubt also so sieht einfach alles mega
cool aus und ich finde wenn man die drei
geräte schon so nebeneinander hat finde
ich sie schon mal extrem gut auf und die
haben wir deswegen auch mit dem holz
kombiniert weil es einfach echt schön
aussieht werden und die geräte die haben
halt echt voll drauf also damit kann
auch der murat kochen und backen denn
die haben zum beispiel als ich zeige
jetzt nicht alles es würde den rahmen
dieses videos springen aber die haben
zum beispiel eine es ist funktion und da
kann man wirklich auch wenn man nichts
mit kochen und backen zu tun hat einfach
meine rezepte nehmen und dann übernimmt
der backofen die einstellung komplett
selber wählt dann die heiz aus de bug
temperatur unter noch die zeit und ihr
müsst einfach nichts mehr machen außer
das gargut in den backofen
hineinzustellen und was wir auch machen
könnt das geht auch mit der app also mit
meiner eigenen app der wir dieses jahr
ja gelohnt da könnt ihr einfach ein
rezept auswählen und das war die
darmfunktion und direkt die backofen
einstellungen an den backofen senden das
ist echt so vereinfacht das heißt ihr
müsst einfach gar nichts mehr machen
und dann wählt man sich einfach ein
rezept aus und kann dann hier ein still
wetter an den ofen senden und jetzt
starten macht es da ofen von ganz
alleine
okay fragt ganz alleine ich habe hier
gedrückt was ich hier auch ganz wichtig
finde und das sollte man wirklich
bedenken nicht vergessen dass die
arbeitsgeräte auch auf arbeitshöhe sind
also ich muss mich nicht bücken um meine
muffins in den backofen zu schieben ich
habe es wirklich hier auf arbeitshöhe da
muss man vielleicht auch ein bisschen
individuell schauen ich glaube mir sind
es einfach ein bisschen höher als in
anderen küchen
aber ich habe hier natürlich auch gleich
die kaffeemaschine und alle drei geräte
sollen eine reihe sehen einfach super
stylisch aus und ich habe jetzt aber
noch überlegt eigentlich müsste die
geschirrspülmaschine auch noch auf
arbeitshöhe das hätten wir auch machen
können indem wir hier praktisch den
schrank erweitern
hier noch die spülmaschine auf augenhöhe
machen denn die benutzte man mehrmals am
tag zu den backofen benutzt man
vielleicht einmal am tag oder maximal
zweimal aber die spülmaschine die hast
du wirklich ständig morgens mittags
abends sitzt an der schule maschine
räumt sie ein ranzen aus wenn du dir
doch auf arbeitshöhe hast dann finde ich
es echt optimal
das habe ich meiner mama in der küche
gemacht die hat sie auf arbeitshöhe und
den backofen auch also wenn man dem
platz hat finde ich sollte man auch noch
die spülmaschine höher setzen und das
hier ist auch so mein lieblings stauraum
denn ich habe alles auf augenhöhe und
habe immer alles schön griffbereit
es hat einfach über den drei
küchengeräten hier diese tipp an
schränke ich habe ich sogar noch in
runde drin
das gab es auch direkt bei küche frei
also direkt vom küchenstudio da könnt
ihr euch informieren
und da habe ich jetzt so ein bisschen
geschirr drin so kommt man nämlich
perfekt dran und es ist einfach nichts
was dahintersteht um mal eben nicht
drankommt das ist so der eine schranke
hier im mittleren schrank habe ich so
ein bisschen geschehe das heißt ja aber
die gläser und hier oben noch eigentlich
sind zwei gläser wir benutzen es aber
als dessert gläser
ich habe hier noch den tee und kaffee so
zum vorrat damit man das eben immer
schön wieder gleichauf füllen kann
und hier links und das ist auch eine
lieblings schränke ist mein backblech
schrank da gibt es nämlich den einsatz
und da kann man wirklich alles schön
lagern ohne dass es über einander steht
weil ich finde das schlimmste was man
machen kann
ist das ganze backblech mit allem
zubehör in den backofen zu stopfen
weil bei mir ist es halt echt so ich geh
blind an den backofen heizen vor ich
gucke da auch gar nicht rein bei mir
steht einfach nie was im backofen
und hier habe ich alles sauber
aufgeräumt und vor allem wenn man die
sachen im backofen lagert hat man das
problem wenn man nämlich mit dem
backofen arbeitet dann muss alles
draußen stehen und dann ist echt ganz
unordentlich wenn man den platz hat
finde ich ist sowas echt richtig
praktisch und hier unter der
kaffeemaschine habe ich direkt noch eine
sowie schublade
aber wie gesagt die küchengeräte die
zeige ich euch in dem anderen video weil
das würde echt den rahmen sprengen
und hier habe ich wirklich in diesen
schränken unser ganzes geschirr
würfelzucker zum beispiel für tee oder
kaffee
ich habe hier immer auch kekse oder auch
früchtetee habe hier die ganzen tassen
und hier auch milch behälter und zucker
behälter damit man das eben schön auf
den tisch stellen kann
wenn's weiter unten habe ich dann die
ganzen teetassen also täglicher und
teetassen die untersetzer und eben
locker oder espresso gläser und hier
rechts zum beispiel habe ich weil ich es
einfach oft brauche meine ganzen back
ringe und programmen die backofen
handschuhe damit ich sie wirklich immer
am backofen direkt griffbereit habe
meine küchenwaage und 1 tiefer dann die
sachen die ich etwas seltener brauche
also sowas wie trat formen guglhupf
obstkuchen form ohne unten habe ich noch
weitere sowie einem muffin form zum
beispiel oder die parkfläche und dann
fehlen im prinzip ich zeige jetzt
einfach nur noch ein paar denn das
andere können wir dann im küchen
organisations video machen habe ich hier
zum beispiel noch meine ganzen abkühlen
gitter oder auch meine porzellan mein
porzellanservice für eben den backofen
also so dass backofen geschehen und dann
habe ich wirklich alles schön hier
sortiert und weiß wo ich alles finde
apropos finden hier habe ich für meine
back vorräte und eigentlich liebe ich
diesen schrank weil das innere so
rauskommt beim aufmachen und man
wirklich auf einen blick alles sieht vor
allem habe ich hier einfach meine ganzen
vorratsdosen die ich beschriftet aber
das sind diese schrank vorratsdosen
da habe ich alles übersichtlich und habe
hier noch die ganzen vorrat sachen in
den verpackungen
das problem ist nur dass ich den schrank
eigentlich gar nicht so voll machen darf
weil er nicht so viel gewicht aushält
also ich hätte mir gewünscht dass ein
bisschen stabiler ist das merkt man
leider er vor mit der benutzung und ich
glaube das nächste mal würde ich sehr so
machen also die tür findet bombastisch
die tür ist er aber das innere das ist
immer so ein bisschen instabil deswegen
habe ich auch nicht alle fächer voll und
da würde ich es erst an so machen
schrank auf und dann in den schubladen
und schubladen einfach immer etwas
stabiler sind als so eine konstruktion
aber wenn ihr sagt ich habe sowieso
keine zehn kilo mehl dann finde ich den
schrank geht ja deswegen habe ich auch
meine mail vorräte nicht hier sondern
hier habe ich zwei große schranktüren
die eine tafel optik haben aber eben
auch eine tafel beschichtung das heißt
ich kann hellwig ist mit kreide
draufschreiben oder darauf malen die
kinder schreiben immer mal gern was
drauf oder wenn wir besuch kriegen
schreiben war herzlich willkommen lieber
spielen und die türen die kann man hier
ganz einfach versenken
denn ich wollte zwar türen haben mit
ihren schubladen aber eben keine türen
die rumstehen weil die stehen dann halt
echt im weg rum und deswegen haben wir
das hier so gemacht
wir sind die türen weg und du kannst
halt wirklich auch den schrank einfach
mal offen stehen lassen und hier habe
ich unser geschirr drin was wir ebenso
zum täglichen gebrauch haben stehen den
schubladen weil sie wirklich total
stabil sind und da einige kilo
reinpassen
und hier auf augenhöhe einfach die
vorräte die ich immer braucht nur so
mehl und zucker und meine im blech da
oben noch mein weg begründet das brauche
ich auch immer bei torten und hier
weiter unten habe ich dann auch wieder
auszüge weil es einfach praktisch ist es
raus sehr einfach auf einen blick was
habe ich drin habe hier auch dieser
innen einteilungen von blumen und ja ist
echt rüber praktisch
und man mag es kaum glauben aber hier
habe ich endlich platz gefunden
wir führen derzeit streusel hätte ich
noch am einfach unten ja die passende
jetzt ihr leid und ich habe da unten
sogar noch ein bisschen stauraum übrig
habe ich nämlich auch noch meine vorräte
in der tür aber finde ich gar nicht
schlimm denn von alleine füllt sich der
raum kann man nie zu viel haben
und hier vorne haben wir dann unsere
küchen insel die natürlich so der
zentrale punkt von allem sind denn da
wird am meisten gearbeitet und geschafft
mit märz auf makrophagen und hier haben
wir uns überlegt dass wir einfach zwei
waschbecken integrieren denn der weg von
hier nach da ist auch ziemlich groß und
gerade für die videos was auch ganz
praktisch denn hier kann ich auch was ab
gießen oder was zeigen direkt am
waschbecken und werden bei beiden
waschbecken beide von blancco haben wir
auch eine abdeckung das ist auch ganz
praktisch da hinten der holz abdeckung
die man so komplett rüberschieben kann
so kann man auch mal so zwei gläser
verstecken die jetzt nicht mehr in die
spülmaschine gepasst haben
die man aber auch nicht per hand
wegwaschen will und hier haben wir noch
eine glasabdeckung die finde ich auch
schön die habe ich mal da mal nicht also
so wie wir das gerade gefällt und was
sich auch bei den blancos spülbecken
schön finde die haben dieses system
spülbecken das heißt ich habe nicht
einfach nur ins spülbecken sondern ich
habe hier zum beispiel noch eine zweite
ebene und kann hier wenn ich
beispielsweise nudeln abgießen will den
topf erst mal hier in zwischenlagern
kann hier aber auch eine schale mit
gemüse lagern das schön hier abspielen
hier wieder darzulegen
also ich habe im prinzip eine
arbeitsfläche auf einer arbeitsfläche
und sozusagen das waschbecken wirklich
komplett ausgenutzt
blanco kommt übrigens aus oberderdingen
das ist hier bei uns in der region und
da arbeiten auch freunde bei uns
deswegen kennen wir die auch und die
sind wirklich absoluter marktführer also
egal in welchem haushalt ich reingehe
ich sehe immer spülbecken von blanco und
auch den mülleimer systeme und an der
spüle haben wir hier die armaturen
die sind von hans kohl und die habe ich
auch auf der messe entdeckt auf der
küchenmesse und zwar wartet eine messe
und am küchen stand von hansgrohe haben
kinder gearbeitet also freiwillig die
haben da plätzchen gebacken sind immer
mit an spülbecken dran und da hab ich
wirklich ganz einfach gesehen wie
kinderleichte bedienung ist nämlich oft
im alltag so man hat zum beispiel den
topf möchte dass abschnitten oder möchte
wasser rein geben und haben dann
praktisch direkt hier drunter gehen und
weil ich jetzt keine hände frei hat
mache ich einfach den da mit dem
ellbogen
wasser an kühlwasser rein machst wasser
wieder aus und für kinder ist es eben
auch ganz praktisch ständig habe jetzt
nicht immer ein hocker hier außer da
vorne aber die ella kommt auch mal ganz
kurz er will ihre hände waschen da vorne
kommt sie nicht dran also kann sich hier
einfach kurz tippen ihre hände waschen
weder tippen und ausmachen und das haben
wir hier aber eben auch da hinten da
hinten ist es eben an der vorderseite
hiess es an der oberseite und die haben
wir einfach noch diesen auszug damit ich
wirklich auch mal schön was abspielen
kann oder eben direkt in den topf
reingehen kann also da gibt es auch
wirklich ganz viele verschiedene
ausführungen und ich glaube die muss man
einfach mal live sehen und sie live auch
mal anfassen und ausprobieren
wenn jetzt hier auch eine matte version
dies auch recht gut weil sie einfach gar
nicht flecken anfällig ist also die
bleibt immer schön sauber und wir haben
alle armaturen alle im ganzen haushalt
auch in den bädern alle von hansgrohe
weil die rechnet ob wirklich eine top
qualität haben und immer ein schönes
design und jetzt sich jetzt ein bisschen
wasser gesammelt und herz von
elektrischen stöpsel gipfels auf
hochdeutsch stöpsel stöpsel ich weiß
nicht wie man dazu sagt das ist bei uns
im stöpsel und hier ist der stöpsel
frisch und den gibt's entweder manuell
manche sind auch eben waschbecken drin
und wenn's blau beleuchtet heißt der
stöpsel ist aktiv also das waschbecken
wird verstopft und wenn man drauf drückt
und es nicht mehr leuchtet heißt
waschbecken ist offen
oder ich drücke und kann das waschbecken
fühlen wenn ich zum beispiel spielen
möchte als bei uns heißt das stück
ich habe ich übrigens ein handtuch
leiste hingehängt die habe ich aus dem
supermarkt ich habe ja so ne griff lose
küche de habe keine griffe dran weil die
mir einfach nicht gefallen also egal
welche griffe ich bisher gesehen habe
haben wir bisher noch nicht gefallen und
zwar immer so eine stolperfalle für mich
ich hatte immer blaue flecken am
oberschenkel weil ich immer daran
streift ich weiß noch in der alten küche
habe ich mir einmal soweit die komplette
hose zerrissen natürlich einfach hängen
geblieben bin und so war ein kompletter
riss und die habe ich einfach noch so
eine handtuch leiste die kann ich auch
überall hin hängen
die kann nicht kleiner machen und größer
und hier einfach die handtücher trocknen
ja
also viele trocknen sie am backofen aber
ich finde das sieht einfach immer so
unaufgeräumt aus deswegen mache ich das
lieber nicht und so eine handtuch leise
dies nicht einfach hier rechts und links
vom herd habe ich so einen kleinen
apotheker auszug ein cooking assistent
den rechts nutze ich allerdings nicht
zum kochen sondern auch er noch für
reinigungsmittel die ich einfach nicht
da vorne brauche und zum beispiel
kaffeemaschinen reinigungs tabs und
entkalker die habe ich direkt hier
gegenüber von der kaffeemaschine und
auch reinigung deshalb weil ich hier
auch unsere zentrale stück zucker anlage
drin hab die hatte ich euch mal gezeigt
als sich die rohre verlegt habe und wir
haben die im prinzip ihren der küche
integriert
und dann kann ich sie hier raus nehmen
und wenn ich mal geprügelt habe einfach
vier direkt abziehen oder auch mal ganz
schnell die schubladen säubern oder auch
mal hier alles was darunter fällt und
dann wird der komplette direkt praktisch
von hier bis ans andere ende der welt
gezogen
nein nicht ganz aber bis in den
technikraum und einmal habe ich das hier
also praktisch mit diesem schlauch und
wir haben den staubsauger abzug von
thomas auch hier unter dem waschbecken
und den kann man dann ganz einfach mit
dem fuß bedienen das heißt wenn ich weg
zumal was geprügelt habe oder
verschüttet habe dann hole ich mir einen
besen und kann das hier davor kern den
wesen habe ich auch einfach immer in der
küche und dann mache ich das so kann das
hier ist mit dem fuß öffnen
und so ist der schmutz einfach wirklich
ganz schnell weg ja aber ich war hier
vorne stehen geblieben nachdem apotheker
schrank also nachdem koch assistent
schrank kommt auch direkt um die
herdplatte und das ist eigentlich so auf
der insel der zentrale punkt finde ich
weil da eben gekocht wird und da außen
herum wird eben alles vorbereitet und
hier rechts von der herdplatte habe ich
im prinzip platz für dieses
schneidebrett ich habe eben so viel
platz dass ich hier am waschbecken das
gemüse und obst und alle lebensmittel
vorbereiten kann und waschen kann
hier kann ich sie dann schneiden und
hier dann direkt kochen und links sommer
kochfeld habe ich einfach so viel platz
dass dann der küchenmaschine hinpasst
oder eine auswahl matte und da habe ich
einfach genügend platz zum arbeiten was
ich hier am herd immer brauche sind
meine werkzeuge
ich habe zwar den großen teil hinter
hinter mir in der schublade
aber die sachen die ich jeden tag
braucht sowas wie schneebesen citrus
pressetext
die habe ich einfach hier drin weil es
eben praktisch ist und ich habe es
einfach schön griffbereit und einstauben
tut es nicht weil ich es wirklich
einfach jeden tag benutzt und einmal die
woche räume ich dann auf spiel den
werkzeughalter und dann ist er eben auch
immer schön sauber
und hier habe ich meine herdplatte auch
eine bosch serie 8 herdplatte und wäre
vielleicht das alte küchen video kennt
der weiß dass ich bei der alten küche
echt am falschen ende gespart habe also
da habe ich wirklich die küche zuerst
geplant und ganz zum schluss blieb halt
kein budget mehr und ich habe einfach
die eigenmarke des küchenstudios
genommen und habe wirklich ganz ganz
nicht nicht mal günstiger sondern wir
die spiele geräte genommen und ich hatte
dann echt zu kämpfen ich muss das sofort
direkt nach dem ersten tag die
spülmaschine austauschen weil die
einfach nicht gewaschen hat ich habe den
herd austauschen müssen die backöfen die
habe ich zwar noch lange benutzt aber
die waren einfach mich wirklich
funktionstüchtig weil sie die temperatur
nicht gehalten haben und mich dann auch
echt viel misslungen weil einfach von
biscuit wenn der temperatur schwankungen
drin sind gerne auch mal zusammenfällt
und da habe ich wirklich daraus gelernt
das heißt auf die qualität der geräte
kommt es wirklich an also da finde ich
darf man nicht sparen zumindest nicht am
falschen ende
und deswegen habe ich hier auch die
serie 8 die sind alle auch home connect
fähig das heißt ich kann alles schön mit
meinem handy verbinden
und ich habe hier einfach funktionen
drin wie zum beispiel hier am topf da
klebt hier so ein kleiner magnet und
zwar ist hier ein temperaturregler drin
ich brauche also zum beispiel eigentlich
gar keine fritteuse sondern kann hier
mein frittierfett einfüllen habe hier
den knopf drum macht die herdplatte an
und das regelt einfach die temperatur
genauso wie beim pfannkuchen backen da
kann ich auch die temperatur einstellen
der pfannkuchen verbrennt nicht und ich
habe wirklich konstant eine gleiche
bräunung und natürlich habe ich hier
auch die herdplatte so dass ich hier
eben auch meinen teppan yaki kohl
auflegen kann oder die grillplatte und
kann auch große gusseisen töpfe eben
auflegen und die volle fläche des sharan
fans nutzen dieses ceranfeld es jetzt
ganz neu ich hatte vorher nämlich 1 wo
praktisch der komplette ceran fläche war
und rechts und links war der mulden
lüfter
damit war ich nicht ganz so zufrieden
vor allem weil man es händisch aufmachen
musste also da muss ich ganz ehrlich
sein
jetzt haben was hier in der mitte und
die reinigung ist auch ganz einfach ich
kann das hier nämlich rausnehmen alles
schön reinigen wieder einsetzen und es
ist halt echt super schmal und
verbraucht echt kein platz auf dem herd
als ich verliere hier keine weitere
zusätzliche herdplatte und normalerweise
finde ich eigentlich abzüge also
dunstabzugshauben
der decke hängen immer besser weil ich
meine der dunst und der rauch und alles
was hier so entsteht passiert hier und
zieht sowieso nach oben
aber natürlich sieht es immer ganz ohne
elegant aus vor allem bei mir hier in
den videos geht einfach nicht ich kann
hier keine jungs abzugshaube hängen von
bosch gibt es aber auch eine lösung die
kann man praktisch runterfahren die gab
es jetzt auf der ifa zu sehen
die ist echt schön hier geht's leider
nicht wegen unserer deckenkonstruktion
drüben bei uns in der familie küche da
jetzt gehen da überlegen wir uns das
sogar noch und wenn ihr könnt dann macht
es wirklich so dass ihr die abluft nach
draußen führt also es gibt zwar hier ich
habe jetzt hier auch einen filter drin
das ist auch okay aber nach außen führen
ist einfach finde ich immer viel viel
besser
aber dann macht es nicht so dass direkt
neben dem kirchenfenster ist man dann ja
kommen was auch nicht nach außen führen
das hatten wir auch in unserer alten
wohnung also in der allerersten da war
so die abluft direkt neben dem fenster
fenster und deswegen da kommt man dann
nicht praktisches fenster offen haben
und die dunstabzugshaube laufen lassen
denn dann wird auch eingezogen
na ja das hatte ich ganz so intelligent
aber es war okay ja so viel zur platte
und wie gesagt elektroaltgeräte machen
wir einfach am besten ein eigenes video
schreibt gerne in die kommentare was er
über die kochfelder wissen wollt oder
über die backöfen über die spülmaschine
oder die kühlschränke haben wir gleich
noch zwei steckdosen installieren lassen
damit ich einfach direkt am herd strom
habe und hier habe ich dann eine
schublade da sind alle meine gewürze
drin und ich habe wirklich viele gewürze
deswegen habe ich auch die komplette
platte damit abgedeckt und direkt
darunter auch die töpfe weil ich die
eben auch direkt am herd brauche
hier links haben wir dann aus zog das
ist auch der koch assistent als zu
heißen einfach diese auszüge vor allem
die die eben diese funktionen haben wie
hier rechts da könnte ich zum beispiel
auch koch dafür noch einstecken
aber ich habe ja mein werkzeug
aufbewahrungs tool auf der arbeitsplatte
und hier habe ich einfach alles was ich
auch so jeden tag brauche wie öl und
essig oder hier oben eben die kleineren
sachen wibag trance prey hier meinen
blitzer schnee der oft zum einsatz kommt
oder auch mein mann ist der extrakt und
die aromen tonka passte alles immer
sozusagen griffbereit und ich hier habe
ich einfach noch so eine kleine kiste
mit rein gemacht die ich auch schön
verschieben kann
und dann bleibt eben auch alles
ordentlich und hier habe ich dann noch
meine schieber hier zum beispiel meine
ganzen aufbewahrungs dosen oder
schneidebretter und obendrüber meine
geschirrtücher und schürzen weil ich die
eben auch jeden tag brauche ach und hier
noch in der zwischen schublade
ich finde die zwischen schubladen sind
einfach die besten vor allem mit den
einteilungen so bleibt echt alles
ordentlich ja ich hatte sogar kurz
überlegt weil hier eben auch viele über
sind in der küche dass ich mal fotos
macht den schubladen und das bei mir
rein läge dann weiß nämlich jeder ganz
genau wo was hingehört macht echt so hat
es früher in den schulküchen nehme ich
auch gemacht wenn meine schüler dann
wussten nämlich auch alles hingehört ja
so war das allgemein solltet ihr auch
darauf achten dass ihr genügend
steckdosen habt und da könnt ihr auch
wirklich beim küchenplanung schon
überlegen wo stelle ich meine
arbeitsgeräte hin
ich habe jetzt hier rechts und links
hinter mir direkt ganz viele steckdosen
an der leiste weil ich da meine
küchenmaschinen habe ich habe hier am
herd noch zwei steckdosen dran und auch
hier außen an der insel ganz praktisch
finde ich auch steckdosen die man in der
arbeitsplatte hat aber da setzt man sich
halt fest also wenn man die
arbeitsplatte einmal durch bord hat hat
es durch sport dann bleibt die steckdose
da auch denn die arbeitsplatte detox man
nicht einfach mal so und deswegen würde
ich mir das immer ganz gut überlegen
aber wenn ihr wisst da möchte ich
arbeiten dann macht es da auf jeden fall
hin und ich denke mir immer lieber eine
steckdose zu viel als eine zu wenig ja
und weil das hätte ich im alltag recht
auch wenn du eine steckdose zu wenig
hast in der küche
jetzt seid ihr gerade sozusagen wie ein
tessins als auch hier steht immer unsere
kamera an der decke das ganze equipment
mit licht
und hier oben noch eine kamera das haben
wir früher immer in der alten wohnung
als auf- und abbauen müssen jeden tag
deswegen haben wir eben auch bisschen
großzügig geplant damit wäre das nicht
mehr machen müssen und ihr seht jetzt
sozusagen die rückseite meiner küchen
insel dies auch voll mit schubladen und
da habe ich einfach schubladen gewählt
die wirklich von oben bis unten durch
cremes sind da haben einfach mit der
claudia besprochen es sieht hübscher aus
wenn es wirklich eine durchgehende
platte ist als wenn man drei
verschiedene hat also drei
unterschiedliche und innen drin habe ich
aber noch zwischen schubladen und hier
haben wir einfach auf stylischen also
wegen der optik noch diese öffnung mit
dem licht und da können wir dann immer
mal wieder was rein stellen ich kann
nicht mal so zwei drei schränke zeigen
aber den rest würde ich euch einfach im
küchen organisations video zeigen aber
hier vorne zum beispiel da habe ich so
ein bisschen von land und zucker passten
und verpassten drin alles schön in den
zwischen schubladen
so finde ich auch wenn man alles und
habe einfach alles griffbereit und unten
kann ich dann immer schön die hohen
sachen rein stellen oder hier drüben zum
beispiel habe ich dann noch meine
garching boards oder die ganz großen
karaffen die wasserbehälter hier noch
meine easy flaschen was ich eben auch
häufig benutze oder auch meiner dies
erkläre die habe ich hier alles schön
ordentlich acht restaurants sich zeigen
muss die flasche geliebt der morath und
ich auch da kann man nämlich
sprudelwasser machen war das zeige ich
euch kurz
nicht so da kapsel
die sind übrigens recyclebar und dann
kommt da ganz einfach kaltes wasser rein
man kann man das noch aromatisieren zb
und durch den druck der jetzt gleich
dritten entsteht geht das aroma von der
zitrone oder von der minze direkt ins
wasser über also es muss man nicht
ziehen sondern es ist sofort
aromatisiert jetzt einfach mal
verschließen aufschrauben dann hat man
halt echt direkt pudel wasser
[Applaus]
und die flasche sieht schön aus auf dem
tisch und man muss keine kisten
schleppen ja jetzt bin ich sozusagen mit
dem innenleben fertig das war der teil
den man im küchenstudio eigentlich nie
macht weil in küchen zentren der man
einfach keine zeit der berater steht an
da hat der sucht mit der die fronten aus
und die arbeitsplatte aber über das
innenleben spricht irgendwie keiner und
für mich ist es innenleben das
wichtigste weil das eben das praktische
ist die küche muss funktional sein der
muss gut geordnet sein und dann kann ich
mir gedanken darüber machen wie sie
aussieht also haben jetzt den innenteil
hinter uns gebracht und jetzt kommen wir
zur optik und da finde ich fällt sofort
bei uns zumindest ins auge die
arbeitsplatte also bei uns kommen
wirklich ganz viele besucher und freunde
und das erste worauf ich angesprochen
werden ist die arbeitsplatte und auf die
muss ich sagen habe ich mich richtig
lange gefreut haben die arbeitsplatte
entdeckt in österreich da waren wir
gerade bei lok schon in diesem muster
haus und mir war es einfach wichtig dass
ich eine arbeitsplatte wähle die
praktisch ist also dass ich eben auch
etwas heißes darauf stellen kann was
nicht zerkratzt was nicht verstaubt er
habe ich weiß noch in unserer ersten
küche da hatten wir eine diva optik und
die hatte total schnell kratzer ich habe
da mal messer abgelegt das messer hat
ein bisschen eingeschnitten und diesen
katzer hast du einfach immer gesehen
in der zweiten küche die die auch kennt
aus der hellen küche da war es so da ist
ja mal eine küchenwerkzeug runter
gefallen und ich hatte sofort backen
drin
die auch nie mehr wieder weg gingen und
die hat man immer gesehen und eine
freundin von mir die hatte eine helle
arbeitsplatte und bei ihr dürfte ich zum
beispiel geschälte karotten nicht
ablegen weil es exakt hatte auf hör auf
da gibt's gleich flecken und ich krieg
nie mehr wieder raus also wusste ich
okay
bei unserer letzten küche die wir uns
sie zu holen muss eine arbeitsplatte her
die wirklich gut und stabil ist wo ich
keine angst haben muss dass die kinder
was drauflegen oder dass der borat in
die gläser abstellt und ich flecken
krieg und ich will einfach eine fläche
haben wo ich was abstellen kann ohne
topf untersätze
und deswegen haben wir uns für stein
entschieden es gibt wirklich auch viele
andere materialien
aber du hast da intern kunststoff stein
gemisch oder du hast komplett nur
kunststoff dann kannst du nur bis 200
grad und dann sag ich ja und was ist
wenn ich jetzt eine pizza machbar 205
gerade das war halt immer so das problem
und die haben wir entdeckt in österreich
da waren wir nämlich damals immer luxus
showroom in diesem haus und haben uns
praktisch diese smart home angeschaut
haben dann acht gewohnt und alles so
entdeckt und erlebt und zum einen hat
mich die optik fasziniert weil es
einfach so ein schöner naturstein ist
und zum anderen und das hat mich echt wo
sie fangen total geflasht
ich glaube geflasht cottbus mora
positioniert aber geflasht denn diese
steinplatte die ist teilweise über 200
millionen jahre alt und dann hast du
hier drinnen das seht ihr es von dort
aus nicht aber hier einfach eine
bedienung für den smart und du kannst
wenn du möchtest ein ganzes haus damit
steuern schon krass also 200 millionen
jahre alt und dann so eine moderne
technik und das haben wir eben mit
unserem luxusmarken gekoppelt und zwar
hast du hier bieten lichtschalter an der
wand also hier dieses pad der mitte
haben wir zumindest so programmiert dass
kann jeder individuell machen
in der mitte steuern wir das licht
rechts oben und rechts unten die
jalousien die musik und links oben und
links unten die jalousie und eigentlich
braucht man es nicht im alltag weil das
smarthome eben schon so eingestellt ist
wie wir es haben wollen also in manchen
räumen wie zum beispiel im badezimmer
ist es so wir betreten den raum die
musik geht an das stimmungs nicht geht
an
hier in der küche haben das nicht so
denn wenn ich drehe habe mache ich
einfach filmdreh modus und dann ist
praktisch die musik deaktiviert und wenn
ich reinkomme verändert sich das licht
auch nicht eben wegen den wegen der
kameratechnik aber ich kann von hier aus
alles steuern und zwar mache ich es
einfach so ich aktiviere hier die
lichter und dann seht ihr hier schon
ich kann jetzt zum beispiel die musik
anmachen ich kann es jetzt noch nicht
abspielen weil dann das video gesperrt
wird weil bei mir läuft aber ich mache
es gleich wieder aus oder ich kann die
chance sieht einfach runterfahren
die lektion bedienung die kann man
einbauen muss man aber nicht mal bekommt
die straße arbeitsplatte natürlich auch
ohne meine mama hat zum beispiel hat
gesagt sie braucht es jetzt nicht oben
in ihrer küche da haben was nicht
eingebaut aber ich fand's bei mir ganz
praktisch vor allem wenn ich wirklich
mal musik anmachen will
und ich brauche kein italienisch kann
ich hier einfach dran da kann ich auch
mehlige hände haben und es funktioniert
alles und fertig die arbeitsplatten die
kommen aus oberösterreich und ich warte
auch schon dort im straßer werk und habt
ihr leben johannes besucht und das sind
wirklich so schöne platten drin da
gibt's sogar komplette inseln
dies sind aus einem stein gemacht also
das sieht wirklich die oberfläche
genauso aus wie die fronten der küche
richtig schön & noble und die haben auch
unten eine beleuchtung wie ich in der
arbeitsplatte bzw auf der insel und das
sieht es aus als wird zum kompletter
stein einfach in der küche schweben und
man kann mit so einer arbeitsplatte
wirklich jede küche aufwerten
also ich glaube das schlimmste was dir
machen könnte ist euch eine schöne küche
zu kaufen die fronten auszuwählen das
innenleben genial zu machen und dann
irgendwie so eine kunststoff
arbeitsplatte nehmen weil die einfach
mit der zeit zum einen kaputt geht und
einfach nicht hochwertig aussieht und so
eine straße arbeitsplatte die sind echt
nicht teurer als viele andere
arbeitsplatten die gibt es auch in jedem
küchenstudio also da bist du einfach nur
nachfragen und sagen ich möchte eine
straße arbeitsplatte und da kauft ihr
euch was einfach fürs leben die geht
nicht kaputt
das ist einfach träge ist eine
investition fürs leben und damit könnt
ihr auch eine günstige küche aufwerten
also auch wenn die küchenmöbel nicht
ganz so toll sind oder einfach
neutralweiß können das ohne arbeitsplatz
drauflegen und die küche sieht wirklich
richtig hochwertig aus
tom kamera mit strom wasser oder da
musst du nicht nach einem machtgerangel
skeptiker aber hier ist dein leben
kontinents verstärken das weißt du wer
nicht dass die russischen kunden deren
karte halber teelöffel oder so also
nicht zu viel wird sich auch ganz
erheblich
vorteile bringt schon gebrannte wandel
mit der packung gebrannte mandeln für
uns bringt uns weiter mit
man sieht übrigens nicht aufhören zu
essen
du bist in bombay mumbai und dann könnt
ihr allgemein noch mit accessoires
arbeiten die euch den alltag in der
küche erleichtern wie zum beispiel hier
hinten diese werkzeugleiste da hängt
jetzt zwar gerade dekoration dran ist
aber auch ganz praktisch normalerweise
habe ich da auch meine küchenhelfer mit
dran und kann da einfach individuell die
haken dran machen oder wegnehmen und
wirklich auch schön variieren eben das
hinhängen was ich gerade brauche habe
ich hier zum beispiel noch dieses
gewürzregal das habe ich auch im
küchenstudio bekommen bei der claudia
und da habe ich einfach die gewürze
drauf und die sachen die ich jeden tag
braucht als das salz dann backpulver
natron sommerparty chilli und minze das
sind wirklich so meine top acht die ich
immer habe und ich hab dir hier
beschriftet und auch direkt hier unten
beschriftet damit keiner eine
reihenfolge und meine ordnung
durcheinander bringt um das glas weg sie
aber wieder zurück kommt gut dass jetzt
gerade noch in benutzung
aber das kommt dann auch wieder hier
zurück es findet den weg wieder zurück
einen platz was sich in der küche auch
immer schön finde sind frische kräuter
ich habe vor meine kräutertee
draußen und da wächst auch das kraut
wirklich am allerbesten
aber wenn ihr wirklich ein bisschen
basilikum oder andere frische kräuter in
der küche haben wollt könnt ihr hier mit
den zwei top system arbeiten
damit habe ich echt ganz gute
erfahrungen gemacht und das basilikum
was eigentlich am schnellsten wirklich
immer ein geht bleibt auch wirklich tage
und wochen lang frisch und dann kann man
das hier gleich abernten sofort in der
soße mit verarbeiten und fertig ein ganz
großes thema in der küche sind auch die
beschläge wie öffne ich schubladen und
türen und ich haben wir überall dieses
pushte oben das heißt ich aber keine
griffe ich drücke drauf der schrank geht
auf und ich kann wieder zu drücken
hier unten auch vor allem ist ganz
praktisch hier weiter unten nehme ich
einfach meine crocs zu öffnen und die
kann ich dann das schwung wieder
zugeschrieben
oder hier weiter oben kann ich auch mal
bin ich wirklich irgendwie hände voll
hat kann ich so die hüfte nehmen oder
ihn dann doch einfach kurz die hand
man sollte finde ich nicht so viele
beschläge miteinander mischen das heißt
wenn man jetzt sagt ok ich hab' ich
pushte open dann sollte man es
vielleicht überall machen aber an
manchen stellen macht auch gar keinen
sinn
es gibt nämlich auch beschläge die
elektrisch funktionieren das heißt man
geht hin und dann merkt da schrank
einfach auch hier ist jemand und geht
von alleine auf so wollten wir es
ursprünglich auf dieser seite machen
aber dann war es halt immer so das habe
ich dem küchenstudio ausprobiert und
stellt es so dar macht gerade was und
dann schubst dich ständig der schrank
auf und es ist schon ziemlich doof
deswegen haben es auf der seite nicht
und haben hier einfach diese griffleiste
oben wo was elektrisch hacken oder auch
haben ist hier aber das ist ein bisschen
blöd deswegen hab ich ausgestöpselt denn
du stehst dann hier und stößt gerade was
und dann geht er auch ständig der
schrank auf ja damals nicht gemacht
bei den fronten haben wir uns hier
gerade bei der insel und auch hier im
rück bereich führt diese wertung optik
entschieden für die dunkle die gibt es
auch noch in heller und ich fand die
besonders schön und findet ja auch bis
heute noch schön weil sie einfach so
eine schöne matte oberfläche hat auch
ein bisschen struktur hat und dies hat
echt gar nicht anfällig also selbst wenn
man was verkratzt oder etwas drauf kommt
wenn die kinder die sind hier ständig
und hier sind so viele menschen in der
küche man sieht einfach keine
fingerabdrücke und du kannst sie mit
einem ganz normalen geschirrtuch
reinigen ohne dass man sich
polieren muss und deswegen also
hochglanz noch nie so ganz mein favourit
würde ich auch glaube ich nie machen
einfach wegen den ganzen fingerabdrücken
klar wer hochglanz geräte aber dafür
nicht okay die benutzt man ja auch und
dann wischt man es eben weg aber hier
bei der front ich meine man hat ja eine
große front fläche finde ich so schon
ganz schön und die haben wir dann
kombiniert damit so ein bisschen wärmer
aussieht hier mit diesem holz furnier
damals und helles holz genommen und
daneben auch noch echt holzelemente mit
reingenommen und dies hat auch echt
schön vor allem fühlt sie sich wirklich
richtig gut an wie so ein naturholz und
das ganze aber dann kombiniert wie ihr
vielleicht gemerkt habt haben wir keine
küchen rückwand so im klassischen sinn
sondern wir haben einfach eine beton
optik gemacht sondern sichtbar auf es
wird aufgetragen das hatte der murat
gemacht nur roberto mit so einer folie
als wird auf gespachtelt da kommt mir
folie drauf trocknet und da hat man eben
diese schönen löcher hier im beton und
dies auch gar nicht anfällig und da
kümmert es eben ganz schön kombinieren
mit den verschiedenen farben und mit
adecco um er ist irgendwie ganz neutral
kann es aber trotzdem immer wieder
individuell anpassen das finde ich schön
und hier im hinteren bereich beim holz
haben es dann kombiniert mit der klinke
optik und da haben wir einfach diese
fertigen klinker paneele genommen und
angeklebt und die haben wir hier auch im
essbereich und das passt halt echt ganz
schön zu den möbel hat alles so ein
bisschen so ein industriell look und
trotzdem immer irgendwie wurde er im
küchenstudio haben wir dann auch direkt
noch holzelemente erstellen lassen und
das ist echt praktisch denn das
küchenstudio hat direkt einer
schreinerei mit dabei und das haben
wirklich viele küchenstudios deswegen
finde ich echt ganz gut ich haben wir
einfach wie so eine art wahr gemacht
also eine theke die man wirklich
verschieben kann
und ich habe bis jetzt so gewünscht dass
er eben schön breit ist und etwas höher
damit ich auch eine erhöhte
arbeitsplatte hab ich meine dies schon
erhöht also ich habe eine etwas höhere
küche als vielleicht manch anderer
ich glaube wir haben die so bei 95 cm
und hier habe ich mir aber noch eine
höhere gewünscht wenn ich nämlich torten
mache und wirklich viel im stehen
arbeiten dann habe ich hier einfach noch
mal eine höhere fläche damit ich mich
nicht bitten muss und die kann man schön
verschieben kann sie aber auch einzeln
wohin stellen wirklich als theke oder
bar benutzen und es ist echt schön
wer ab und zu und es ist einfach aus
echtem holz richtig massiv also allein
krieg ich die nicht weggetragen auch
nicht zwei frauen
da müssen schon irgendwie so starke
männer dran oder 2 und dann ist es echt
ganz schön und hier drüben haben wir
dann aus dem gleichen material ein regal
erstellen lassen um den kühlschrank
herum
hier haben wir uns seit kühlschrank mit
brennstoff ranch tor bedeutet man hat
hier oben alles nur kühlschrank als ich
eine große fläche und die passt eben
perfekt zu mir denn ich kann hier
wirklich große torten reinstellen dann
nehme ich einfach ein brett raus kann
große lange hohe torten hier platzieren
und am anfang hatten wir auch nur den
einen kühlschrank
er hat am anfang auch noch sturz
ausgereicht hier unten habe ich dann
zwei fächer für tiefgefrorenes aber dann
haben wir ganz schnell gemerkt okay wenn
ich dann echt mal eine große torte
backen und ich mag wirklich viele
trotten brauchen wir eben immer diesen
platz und deswegen gucken wo auch dass
der kühlschrank so weit es geht frei ist
für den täglichen dreh und deswegen
haben wir hier noch einen kühlschrank
wie in der alten wohnung auch dort nur
auf zwei kühlschränke und es ist mehr so
für den vorrat und das ist jetzt ein
zeit weiß seit aber nicht fremd und da
haben uns einfach dafür entschieden weil
wir dachten okay hier rechts haben wir
komplett kühlschrank links gefrierfach
und hier haben wir dann noch für den
sommer eiswürfel fach und das ist halt
auch echt cool
und ja man dann einfach unsere ganzen
torten back und kochgeräte alles immer
schön organisiert und der kühlschrank
der hat sogar eine kamera
das heißt wenn ich unterwegs bin und mir
fällt spontan ein okay ich möchte noch
eine torte backen oder ein rezept kochen
und ich weiß aber gerade nicht ob ich
das darf dann kann ich einfach über mein
handy mich mit der app verbinden und
kann in den kühlschrank reingucken und
weiß dann eben was kaufe ich und was
brauche ich nicht hier habe ich dann
auch das gefrierfach haben auch immer
vorräte vor allem habe ich immer
folgende star ich habe immer seine
produkte da und milchprodukte und mehl
zucker klar aber ich habe auch immer
tief gefrorene früchte da die werden
nämlich erntefrisch direkt eingefroren
und dann habe ich immer was da um ein
leckeres dessert oder motorrads zaubern
muss da nicht extra einkaufen gehen und
die haben wir einfach dieses offene
regale gestalten lassen
und weil es eben eine schreiner arbeit
war und eben individuell war
ursprünglich das sieht man auch wenn man
genau hinschaut ging das regal bis hier
und dann haben wir
den kühlschrank dazu genommen und haben
es dann vom küche frei einfach nochmal
erweitern lassen und so passt einfach
recht perfekt in unsere küche und vor
allem habe ich stauraum für allem eine
tortenplatte für die ganzen gusseisen
töpfe die eben auch schön und schwer
sind die sind dann hier drin und ich
habe sie eben immer griffbereit unter
dieser schiebe theke haben übrigens auch
mein versteck denn ich habe hier immer
auch einen hocker stehen damit ich eben
auch an meine dekoelemente da oben
kommen also an den stauraum an denen ich
so ohne treppe eben nicht dran komme
oder für samira und allard die eben
gerne auch mal in der küche mithelfen um
dieser hocker den gab es auch mit dazu
zur küche den kann man auch
zusammenklappen und direkt unten in so
eine leiste reinschieben
aber ich brauche sie nicht häufig weil
die kinder eben auch draufstehen
deswegen steht da hier bei uns unter der
theke und hier drüben haben wir dann so
unseren f bereich der ästhetisch und ja
hier sitzen wir dann morgens meist
zusammen und besprechen und dann zum
essen zum mittagessen abendessen und
hier haben einfach auf küchenmöbel
genommen und das finde ich auch echt ein
richtig coolen tipp denn wenn ihr in
eurem esszimmer möbel haben wollt also
ein sideboard für geschirr besteck weil
man es eben dann direkt am tisch hat und
dann könnt ihr wirklich küchenmöbel
verwenden denn die könnt ihr wirklich
schwer beladen mit geschirr mit besteck
so dass er wirklich alles direkt am
tisch auch habt und es ist einfach
stimmig
mittlerweile hat man nicht nur einfach
eine küche sondern man hat so und küchen
wohn- ess- und lebensraum
also so dass alles zueinander passt und
das finde ich eigentlich echt am
schönsten
und die haben wir wirklich so ein
kleines sideboard gemacht und hier sind
auch die möbel die offenen regale die
ich auch in der küche habe also alles
hängeschränke den man wirklich auch
schön beladen kann und zudem teppiche
gibt's wirklich eine richtig schöne
geschichte und zwar ist es ein patchwork
teppich dann haben wir auch drüben im
wohnzimmer ins zimmer also den noch mal
wirklich fast überall in allen räumen
der iss aus der türkei und zwar gibt es
in der türkei wirklich haushaltet die
456 teppiche haben meine schwiegermutter
hat sogar mehr
die hat 456 teppich der in jedem raum
und die meisten teppiche sind wirklich
schon jahrhunderte jahre alt und dato
gab es sind freunde von uns er geht
einfach in die haushalte kauften
menschen die teppiche ab die bekommen
dann auch genug geld dafür und vor allem
für teppiche die die meisten 1
wegschmeißen würden und er nimmt die
teppiche die werden dann gewaschen
werden geschoren also kurz geschnitten
werden gefärbt und dann individuell zur
patchwork teppiche zusammengenäht und
das ist wirklich alles handarbeit und
vor allem gibt es mittlerweile einfach
keine echten teppiche mehr die meisten
bestehen aus kunststoff und werden dann
als retro teppich verkauft aber das sind
wirklich teppiche die haben einfach eine
geschichte
jetzt kann es sein dass diese eine fleck
hier 300 jahre alt ist der andere ist
100 jahre alt und diese handgeknüpfte
technik gibt es einfach nicht mehr weil
sie teppiche eben auch unbezahlbar
werden weil keiner mehr da sitzt und
irgendwie drei vier fünf jahre lang
ebenso ein teppich knüpft und das ist
eben eine schöne geschichte vor allem
weil die textile kette einfach am laufen
bleibt es wird nichts weggeschmissen es
wird einfach schön gewackelt sagt man
glaube ich so ganz schön aber dazu gibt
es bald ein video der moral zeigt euch
das nämlich und erklärt euch die ganze
geschichte und zeigt euch auch so die
einzelnen steps und jammer den grünen im
wohnzimmer hat den bund dieser hatte ihn
den hellrosa also die gibt es wirklich
in verschiedenen ausführungen und größen
und wenn wir schon gerade bei handmade
sind dass sie ist eine lampe die hat uns
der vulkan gemacht also besser und
artwork und der vulkan ist ein freund
von uns der gehört eigentlich
mittlerweile schon zur familie also mehr
als freund da macht auch meine ganzen
ort stecker wo immer ganz viele danach
fragen aber er macht sie halt ja für
mich und er sagt er will die gar nicht
verkaufen weil für ihn das ist kein
geschäft sondern er macht einfach weil
es spaß dran hat alles mit der hand
selber zu machen und diese lampen die
macht es so da geht einfach im wald
spazieren mit seinem hund und sieht dann
irgendwie so im altes holz stück oder
irgendwie ein abfall nimmt mit nach
hause und sagt alles was alt ist hat
einfach leben und wenn man es mal kauft
dann hat es einfach kein leben
und deswegen macht er immer so
individuelle kunstwerke aus holz und
beton und irgend welchen materialien dir
halt einfach so findet erfolg haben und
wenn wir gerade beim licht sind das
solltet ihr wirklich nicht
vernachlässigen in eurer küche oder
überhaupt im ganzen haus und in der
wohnung die lichtplanung die ist wichtig
denn ich habe zum einen arbeitslicht das
heißt helles licht zum arbeiten oder
auch beim essen habe ich auch gern
helles licht weil ich einfach sehen will
was auf meinem teller legt und dann gibt
es noch das atmosphären
was ich gerne abends an habe wenn ich
einfach fertig bin und feierabend habe
gegessen habe und aufgeräumt habe dann
habe ich gerne atmosphäre nicht was eben
nicht so blendet und so ein bisschen
weicher ist und gelber ist und das kann
man wirklich ganz gut steuern
wir haben hier über dem esstisch zum
beispiel diese pendelleuchten und die
sind hell wenn wir gerade essen aber ich
kann sie auch dann dimmen oder die
farbtemperatur ändern und das haben wir
alles in unserer lockt so nepp
hinterlegt das heißt beim essen haben
wir dann ein schönes helles licht und am
abend machen wir dann fernsehen licht
oder stimmungs licht und es kann man
sich individuell einstellen so haben wir
das auch hinten mit unseren leuchten und
in der küche drüben da hab ich dann ein
bisschen anders hier habe ich natürlich
damit ihr alles gut sehen könnt wie so
eine art studio beleuchtung also dann
wächst unsere ganzen lichter an die
decke gehängt damit alles gut
ausgeleuchtet ist und damit ich auch
wenn es draußen schlecht ist und betrübt
und wolkig und bewölkt wollte ich sagen
damit wird daneben auch schön filmen
können und wenn das licht aus ist sie zu
übrigens so aus also etwas dunkel und
ich kann auch hier auf meinem touch pad
dann wirklich die lichtstimmung ändern
und beim kochen und bisschen helleres
licht machen und abends wenn es dunkel
ist haben wir hier so atmosphären licht
wo wirklich nur noch die indirekte
beleuchtung an ist und alles so ein
bisschen warm und kuschelig ist und das
ist für uns hier so unser wohnbereich
auch wir arbeiten hier wir leben hier
wir sind hier immer alle zusammen und
wir fühlen uns hier auch echt wohl und
meistens ist sogar so wenn freunde da
sind oder familie dass wir einfach hier
sitzen bleiben weil wir hier kochen hier
essen da dann gemeinsam sitzen und noch
im tee trinken und es ist wunderschön
hier
das war ein küchen video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen und ihr konntet euch
die einen oder anderen tipps und tricks
abschauen
ich hoffe natürlich dass wenn ihr eine
küche plant und euch eine küche
anschaffen wollte dass ihr dann das
ganze vor ort macht dort werden nämlich
gut beraten und wirklich kauf teurer
küche einfach dort wo ihr euch wohl
fühlt wo ihr euch beraten fühlt und wo
die menschen sich auch für euch
interessieren wenn ihr den küchenstudio
reingeht und die berater option fragen
wie kocht ihr zuhause wie groß ist die
familie
was habt ihr für vorleben dann glaube
ich seid ihr wirklich gut beraten und
dann interessieren sich die menschen
auch für euch ich finde aber auch man
muss als käufer wirklich immer fair
bleiben ganz schlimm finde ich es wenn
man sich wirklich vor ort beraten lässt
die pläne raussuchen lässt alles auf was
wirklich skizziert wird und ihr dann
hingeht und irgendwie online bestellt
weil dann fertig ist es echt unfair den
menschen gegenüber die wirklich
gearbeitet haben und geht wirklich beim
küchenkauf nach funktionalität und nicht
nur nach design das design ist wirklich
so das letzte was man sich aussucht
finde ich zumindest denn das innenleben
das ist das womit ihr euch wirklich den
ganzen tag jeden tag das ganze jahr über
beschäftigt und ich werde wirklich auch
ganz bald das organisations video machen
also wenn ihr fragen habt und schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
wenn ihr ein video über alle
küchengeräte haben wohl schreibt auch in
die kommentare
die ein oder andere story habe ich jetzt
bereits schon beantwortet da kamen schon
ganz viele fragen zum backofen zum herz
zum kühlschrank schreibt gerne alles und
in die kommentare dann kann ich nämlich
auch auf eure wünsche eingehen und ich
wünsche euch jetzt viel spaß mit den
anderen videos viel spaß beim kochen und
backen weiterhin und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal